ladies and gentlemen this is a special
moment for me a chance to flub drink at
home sorry this is a special moment for
me the chance to introduce a woman who
is at the top of her craft as a
performer yet who is perhaps admired
even more for who she is as a person
last year's Academy Award winner for
best actress Sandra Bullock
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and it is my honor to present the
nominees for performance by an actor in
a leading role
Javier Ola when you won your Oscar for
No Country for Old Men you managed to
scare an entire nation
with a haircut but even more
impressively than that you have inspired
delighted and moved us and at least two
languages in your films and you do all
of the above in your haunting
performance this year in beautiful copy
air Bardem Jeff dude dude you um
you won this award last year you know I
mean wouldn't it be nice if like you
maybe gave someone else a chance
staggered it a little bit I mean how
much is enough okay think about it but
you are such a good actor that this year
you took on a role that has already won
another actor an Oscar and you made it
indelibly your own when you're strapped
on that eye patch in True Grit Jeff
Bridges
Jesse I'm still waiting feet except my
friend request on facebook serious but
you have captured the spirit of an
entire generation and you've inspired
lonely young men hunched over keyboards
around the world your power is a spark
that connects the social network Jesse
Eisenberg
Colin Colin right here so I hear the the
Queen saw the film she enjoyed it which
is good right as I assume you plan on
going back home sometime
but not only the Queen was inspired but
all of us by the man you played who
struggled so eloquently to achieve his
destiny in the King's Speech Colin Firth
James James oh you're back
James you have so famously played such
icons as James Dean and Alan Ginsberg
but forget all that you are the number
one reason children get picked up late
from school because their mothers are
watching you on General Hospital
hey act was act and none better than you
in the searing and visceral 127 hours
James Franco
and the Oscar goes to colin firth the
King's Speech
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award on a
second consecutive nomination for Colin
Firth he was nominated last year for a
single man
I have a feeling my career's just peaked
no my deepest thanks to the Academy
afraid have to warn you that I'm
experiencing stirrings some in the upper
abdominals which are threatening to form
themselves into dance moves which joyous
as they may be for me it would be
extremely problematic if they make it to
my legs before I get offstage so I'm
going to do my best to be brief with my
gratitude first time for being on this
extraordinary list of fellow nominees
something quite formidable and then
possibly the greatest honor of this all
the crew my fellow cast members those
who are not here and those who are
Jeffrey Helena and guy whose virtuosity
made it very very difficult for me to be
as bad as I was planning to be and David
Seidler whose own struggles have given
so many people the benefit of his very
beautiful voice and Tom Hooper for the
immense courage and clear-sightedness
with which he interpreted that the men
who finished this to the screen Gareth
amel Ian Xavier and of course Harvey who
first took me on 20 years ago when I was
a mere child sensation and all the
people who have been rooting for me back
home
also Jessica Kolstad my friend Paul Owen
Maris and Chris Andrews for bearing with
me through some of the less fortunate
moments as well as the good ones
my very fortunate friendship with the
tomforde who to whom I owe a very big
piece of this and to the anglo-italian
American Canadian access which makes up
my family and Livia for putting up with
my fleeting delusions of royalty and who
I hold responsible for this and for
really everything that's good that's
happened since I met her now if you'll
all excuse me I have some impulses I
have to tend to backstage
[Music]
[Applause]